con una economía en recesión desde hace
dos años la pandemia llegó a argentina
como otro golpe más con una cuarentena
que se decretó en marzo y ha empezado a
flexibilizarse desde mayo la pobreza se
muestra como un indicador al alza en
medio de este panorama según el
instituto nacional de estadística la
pobreza alcanzó en el primer semestre
del año el 49 por ciento de la población
un repunte de más de 5 puntos sobre el
final de año pero según unas
estimaciones anticipadas de la
universidad católica de argentina hasta
junio la pobreza era de entre el 46% y
el 47 por ciento de shock han sido en la
estructura productiva una declinación de
empleo en el cuenta propia incluso
informal bueno entonces mayor pobreza
general todos somos un poco más pobres
ya lo hubiéramos sabido el año pasado
ahora más
durante la cuarentena en argentina se
han destruido tres millones y medio de
puestos de trabajo la mayoría informales
como el de guillermo quien se gana la
vida como vendedor ambulante en eventos
deportivos sobreviví por la familia que
me apoyaba pero era apoyaba también
económicamente porque no tenía ninguna
posibilidad de hacer nada no hay no
habían en ningún evento como pasaría
vender mi trabajo como para hacer el
gobierno ha dado subsidios de unos 125
dólares mensuales a 9 millones de
personas y también promueve los
comedores populares de acuerdo con las
cifras oficiales más de la mitad de los
niños son pobres y en el segundo
trimestre del año la caída del producto
interior bruto fue de un 19,1 por ciento
es el peor dato de este tipo desde que
se realiza el registro incluso superando
el del primer trimestre del 2002 que fue
del 16 3% en medio de la crisis del
corralito